welcome to this meeting of the Herman
Institute's series of workshops and
panels on Human Rights we have tonight
the authors of several of the best new
works books and articles on the subject
of transitional justice their common
theme is justice and politics so back in
the early 1990s advocacy of criminal
accountability for atrocities stressed
morality and law and was extremely
successful and calling attention to the
problem
mobilizing outrage among the public and
energizing activists to work on this
issue
there were also claims made for the
practical beneficial political
consequences of putting perpetrators on
trial justice it was claimed would deter
future atrocities would strengthen the
rule of law and democracy and therefore
pursuing justice through trials would
strengthen peace but at that stage I
think it's fair to say that the
political consequences and strategies of
justice were not the central message at
that time but since that time there's
been tremendous success in mobilizing
energies on this issue and there's been
the creation of the International
Criminal Court
among other organizational successes of
this advocacy movement and so I think
recently it's fair to say that the
debate has been moving more towards
focusing on the politics of justice and
particularly on what are the
consequences for politics of
transitional justice efforts
and that's exactly what our panelists
have been writing about in their books
and articles they've been looking at
such topics as how does the political
setting as especially the power and
interests of key players affect the kind
of justice process that emerges if any
they've been writing about what role
does the threat of legal accountability
play in bargaining with powerful
perpetrators and what role is it
appropriate for that kind of bargaining
to play and they've been writing about
what are the consequences of trials for
the rule of law and democracy so before
I introduce our panelists I'm gonna ask
my colleague Alex Cooley to give you a
bit of an advertisement about a couple
of seminars and workshops that we're
gonna have coming up in the next couple
of weeks in this series just very
briefly as part of the cluster of our
events next week we will have a panel on
the politics of international media
rankings that will feature Leigh Becker
represent from Freedom House Carlene
Carr locker and Ann Nelson and the week
after we will have a panel on the
politics of illicit indicators and the
contestation
of numbers and that will feature Peter
andreas of Brown University author of a
new book and Laura nettle field again
also Sally Mary of NYU and Patrick Ball
of the Benetech corporation so please
please join us of the next couple of
weeks where again we will try bring
together scholars with practitioners for
a productive dialogue on these issues
so tonight for our panel on transitional
justice we have four authors of recent
research-based works and two
distinguished panelists are our authors
begin with routine title
who's the Ernst evil professor of
comparative law and associate director
of the Center for international law at
New York law school and visiting
professor at LSE Rudy is as as I
understand it the person who's actually
coined the term transitional justice
which was the title of her oxford
university press book on this subject
back in 2000 and tonight you'll also be
drawing on her forthcoming book
humanities law after we hear from rooty
we'll hear from professor leslie vinge
Omori
at the University of London School of
Oriental and African Studies she's the
author of a number of articles on
transitional justice in international
security and ethics and international
affairs and other journals and she's
writing a book on transitional justice
then we'll hear from Professor Monika
Nalepa at Notre Dame University she's
the author of skeletons in the closet
which is a book about transitional
justice in Eastern Europe and that'll be
the basis for her talk tonight after
Monica we'll hear from Laura nettle
field who's a postdoctoral fellow at the
Harriman Institute this year associated
with our human rights project and she's
the author of courting democracy in
Bosnia and Herzegovina The Hague
tribunals impact in a post-war State
2010 from Cambridge University Press
right there a book that Richard
Goldstone has praised highly in his
blurb so those are our four presenters
of their research we have two
distinguished commentators Tina
Rosenberg is the winner of the 1995
National Book Award for her book the
haunted land facing Europe's ghosts
after communism and she's also about to
publish a new book which I will plug
it's called join the club how peer
pressure can transform transform the
world
all right their discussion tonight is
Rea Nayar who's the founder of Human
Rights Watch and is currently the
president of the Open Society Institute
so Ruti
please start us off I'm gonna pick up
with where my book left off as you may
recall and the book is mm but it really
took me longer to produce than Tina's
book on Eastern Europe and Latin America
it's a comparative study of transitions
at the time and what I want to talk
about is how the the framing of
transitional justice has changed from
that period to the moment present moment
and in particular the role of human
rights and the subject of the human and
I'm gonna talk about these remarks in
light of a question and pose it in terms
of a question and that is is
transitional justice a human right has
it become a human right question mark so
at the time that we were all many of us
on this panel debating these issues I
remember a debate with Diane or liquor
at the Council on Foreign Relations in
1990 about a debate about whether Latin
America could become a democracy several
countries that were undergoing
transition chile argentina without
trials whether it was possible to have
true democratization and stability
without trials and in particular this
seemed to be clearly happening in shyla
and then later we would see or apply and
even Argentina's starting with Charles
would abandon them and in that time the
conceptualization of transitional
justice seemed to be around a series of
dilemmas and local decision-making and
we thought about that is informed by
domestic law to some extent but really
political questions for political actors
in in those countries
what would alfonsín do what would other
wing do what would the local judiciary
do what would the legislators do and and
so this was the kind and the dilemmas
were framed as two piece versus justice
sometimes truth versus justice often
suggesting that there were Hobbesian
choices and and one would one value
would have to yield to another yeah in
in the current moment and again these
are as a snapshot I spent a lot of the
last 48 hours thinking about the
transitions in the Middle East and
perhaps this will come up in the Q&A at
the present moment this entire way of
thinking about it as a discretionary
matter for local decision-makers seems
to have really fallen away and so that's
what interests me is the change in the
narrative and in particular I'm going to
draw on three sources of illustrations
of this area of law that is in some to
some extent both constraining actors but
also shaping their own discourse and
enabling other sets of choices on the
ground three sources of one is from the
region of Europe the other the Americas
and a thirdly international law
the World Court and the ICC and I know
that other speakers will get into this
as well so this is really a very general
and that is we might think about two
recent cases that came before the
European Court of Human Rights and
intriguingly they relate to this the
subject at hand of the post-communist
MoMA the Balkans conflict and in two
recent cases January 2011 and you can
imagine it's already it's a long time
since the Latin American transitions but
it's also a decade since those conflicts
1991 war crimes where the European Court
of Human Rights held that the
investigations by the Croatian police
and judicial system had were inadequate
and these were cases involving of
Croatian nationals of Serbian origin who
had been taken away in Vukovar and there
were of course conflicts over the
control of that land they were accused
of terrorism and very little information
given these this is the you Lara case
and Scanjet case what's interesting is
these cases come to the attention of the
world through petitioners through the
families right this human subject they
are claiming rights that relate to the
rights to life in the European
Convention and what's interesting is
that well the life is gone right these
are disappearances for the most part and
the court says that there are related
rights that even decades later pertain
to the right to life - to the presume
loss of life and they conclude that that
these rights mean that the state has a
general duty to secure everyone within
their jurisdiction so of whatever
nationality of whatever ethnicity rights
to an effective official investigation
as we'll see this is you know this idea
is not at all radical it had been ruled
on in the late 1980
I'm gonna get into that in Latin America
there were cases holding that there was
a right to an official investigation
what is effective me what is official
mean what is investigation me and what
we'll see is that there are a number of
different bodies that are ruling on
these questions the court says that
official and effective means that it
can't be the police that took them away
and it can't even necessarily be the
local the local units where the
disappearance occurred but that the idea
of an effective investigation means an
independent investigation and you know
as we know even in our more established
system often independence can mean a
change of fora some guarantee of
impartiality and here they said it meant
a judicial investigation so you have a
regional system a regional judiciary
ordering an investigation and they said
that it needs to be prompt and
independent they go on to hold that
there are other rights that pertain and
in particular a ruling that it's a
borderline torture inhuman treatment to
have spent decades not knowing where
your family was and this is very
interesting and also entails families to
reparations now the these cases are just
the most recent and the most dramatic
because they are you know less than a
month ago of the European Court built on
prior jurisprudence coming out of
Turkish Cyprus the Turkish Cyprus
conflict prior disappearances prior
cases defining what is torture so it's a
very interesting body of jurisprudence
that's coming out of the European Court
of Human Rights
now they built on the inter-american
Court and so what's interesting here is
and from a legal perspective is that
they're not compelled they're not bound
by the rulings or the precedents of this
other region and yet the rulings in that
region inform of the the European Court
of Human Rights
specifically in some of these cases cite
cases coming out of massacres in Peru
and disappearances in Honduras the
landmark case in the inter-american
Court since the late 1980s holding that
there is a right of investigation and
this has been now touted as a right to
truth by victims groups it came out of
Honduras of disappearances and Honduras
the famous Velasquez Rodriguez case and
here it's a very interesting question
because the court says that it's it's
really a principle of international law
that reads but into that is read into
the regional system and that the
principle of international law you know
the regional law requires a right to
life under the American Convention but
the body of international law says that
wherever there's a violation of an
obligation there's a duty to investigate
and make adequate reparation so the
courts are themselves engaging in cross
judging if you will of pulling together
looking at different legal materials
that relate to these violations and and
ruling often against the local national
systems political and legal and judicial
actors ruling that they have rights and
that these rights need to be honored in
subsequent cases that have been noted in
the in the press more generally there
are at least three countries where the
the inter-american Court has ruled that
their amnesty laws are no longer viable
certainly most recently Brazil and
before that in regarding Argentina and
in these cases as you can see take us
farther down the road in terms of
judicial activism right because we're
not just talking about a right to truth
and investigation we're talking about a
court saying that beyond the duties to
investigate there are you know that in
overturning the self amnesties for
example in Brazil and in Argentina that
there were attendant duties of
independent prosecution and this of
course will lead us in a moment to the
last Oregon that's functioning today
with an impact on a local
decision-making and that is the
International Criminal Court and here we
you know many of us have have been very
interested in the last decade at the ICC
and what we see is that the court has
taken very seriously its jurisdiction as
complementary to national criminal
jurisdiction the the jurisdiction at the
ICC according to its preamble and
article 1 is that is complementary to
the national criminal courts and what
they what that means so far is unclear
about what if what it means in terms of
the operation of the court is that the
court essentially is reviewing the
actions of national bodies I'm going to
move along obviously there are human
rights implications as we know the
Security Council in a high-profile case
referred a Bashir and r4 to the court
and that's an instance where it could
certainly have implications for peace
negotiations on the ground and I know
that other panelists will get into this
the what I want to end with since there
are a lot of other illustrations and I'm
happy to get into this in Q&A is how
might this encounter with transitional
justice affect our the framing of the
questions right we certainly can see
that that the courts are taking interest
in the nature of the duties and rights
owed to victims victims groups and the
duties bites that states have the duties
of states according to these decisions
extend beyond the state actors to
non-state actors so we're talking that
paramilitary we're talking about
wherever there there are actions that
are imputed to the state and beyond so
it's a very wide-ranging role for the
law one way to think about it is that
the law here is kind of a part of the
shadow or the environment in which
political decisions get made and so part
of what will you get into eyes
in the QA is how these legal
developments the gap-filling functions
of the law where there have been human
rights claims made that pertain to
transitional justice are reshaping the
decision making and dilemmas as they're
perceived by political actors but I just
want to end with a question which is
even if it is now legally a human right
what is the legitimacy of this
development in instances like Uganda
Sudan and Lebanon and perhaps Mubarak
today in Egypt how do these new duties
and rights that are being articulated by
legal bodies how are these shaping that
the decision-making on the ground how
are they affecting the permissible
trade-offs who should decide and what is
the legitimacy of this evolution of
transitional justice
thanks jack and thanks for having me um
I want to pick up on some of the themes
that that that Jack mentioned and also
Rudy and and speak about this this move
towards really looking at impact which
of course is central within human rights
but I want to look specifically at
transitional justice and in particular I
want to look at this in the context of
discussions advocacy and also
scholarship about the impact of
transitional justice or the move by
tribunals and courts to indict and to
engage in situations of ongoing conflict
so let me say a few things about why I
think we've seen the shift and what I
think I take this to be one of the most
crucial changes and I also take it to be
potentially one of the most dangerous
areas for transitional justice to go and
I'll and and along these lines I can
also share a few findings that I've come
up with through my research that cast
some doubt on some of the some of the
arguments that are articulated by
advocates and some of the arguments that
are also being made by academics about
this so the name of the game is impact
and of course this this is a this is a
topic that takes place among I would say
three communities fun dog identify three
communities funders advocates and
scholars and I'm really going to talk
about the last two I've although clearly
the discussions amongst funders are
central and are driving a lot of what's
happening at the level of active
advocacy we convened a meeting in London
a few weeks ago amongst human rights
funders and as one of the leading
funders there said who I won't the name
of whom I won't mention actually an
American thunder who came over which was
the cause of meeting said why should
human rights get a pass and and this
this person was in a sense articulating
what he saw to be would be a shift in
in the criteria that would really drive
programming in the area of Human Rights
and justice and this was really the
theme of the meeting and the meeting was
very interesting because there still was
some debate and this is this is a theme
that I'd like to articulate which is I
think that the the public discourse on
impact is much less nuanced than what I
think is happening and I'm sure all of
you know that better than I do then
what's actually happening behind closed
doors I know that the president of ICT
Jay is here tonight I'm David Colbert
and when he was at our launch of the
London transitional justice Network I
think the quote if I'm wrong please
correct me later on whether we like it
or not the name of the game is impact
that's where we are and then that was on
the record I'm so so it's clearly there
and as Rudy said and as Jack also
mentioned the arguments and the language
used to be very very different I always
think of Diane or and likers Pease named
the duty to prosecute and I think in
that piece she was talking primarily
about a legal duty but clearly we know
that human rights in general and I would
argue also transitional justice has been
thought about historically as being
something that's sacred that it's a
protected space that it's the right
thing to do and I think especially when
we begin to look at the new advocacy
that surrounds interventions in ongoing
conflict that message at the least at
the level of the publicly articulated
message has really very much been lost
and there's been a triumphalism about
consequences why is this I would just
flag three things very quickly one is
that many of the institutions especially
the ICTY at the moment when it was
engaging in Bosnia and indicted
Milosevic in Kosovo was still a very new
institution it was created in the middle
of an ongoing conflict so ergo here we
are and in order to actually to justify
in order to justify one's role I think
in the time of ongoing conflict it
becomes very difficult to talk about
things other than impact and impact in
these situations I think has become
narrowed to be
about arguments on behalf of the role of
transitional justice in bringing and
delivering peace and deterring future
conflicts so it's really deterrence and
peace that I think has been narrowed in
on what's the problem the stakes are
extraordinarily high when we're talking
about ongoing conflict the expectations
one advocacy takes this line I think
become increasingly high and in a sense
that's a that's a problem that is
constructed in part by it by advocacy
and the evidence doesn't seem to justify
the articulated arguments so let me show
you just a few slides that that what
what I've done in my research is to put
a day to put together data set that
looks specifically at international
justice in cases of war and post-war so
conflict and post-conflict situations
I'm not looking at all transitions and I
put this up here for two reasons I
should say that in general my
orientation towards research is not
quantitative I'm deeply deeply skeptical
and as I sure as I imagine many of you
are of quantitative research however the
academic research on the impact of
transitional justice has gone in this
direction okay so I think it's
extraordinarily important despite the
fact that most of my work is qualitative
to begin to put this up here so the the
first two slides are intended to
demonstrate one thing that the that the
variation over time isn't really doesn't
look the same as the story that we're
being told both by some scholars
Katherine's thinking I think most
notably but also by the general line
that we read which is that international
justice is more prolific there's a lot
more going on now I had I had breakfast
this morning with Pablo and he said you
know the problem with these people who
talk about amnesties is that they don't
separate out amnesties are not amnesties
are not amnesties so what I've tried to
do is to really look at this and and
it's it's a little bit difficult to see
where you are but if you look at the
second slide you can see that actually
there are the the trend in terms of the
overall trend in the use of amnesties
has actually accelerated that's
increased as has trended every other
mechanism trials and truth Commission's
but limited it limited amnesties are
also increasing so there is something
that's changing and that's really quite
significant relative to general
amnesties but the story is still very
different from what we're hearing this
slide I put up because it separates out
what's happening when amnesties are
embraced by domestic actors and what's
happening when amnesties are embraced by
international actors and here I think
it's actually very significant in
demonstrating what I take to be a trend
which is that there is a that there is a
very big difference between the
International and the local in terms of
not only practice but arguably
preferences and so if you look at the
green and purple lines which are 1990 to
2007 at the top of the charts
those are domestic amnesties both
general and limited and they're they're
being used a lot more often than
embassies that are embraced by the
international community
um this slide I put up because it tells
us some interesting things now these are
correlations and a lot of the academic
research that's being done on impact is
trying to prove which I don't personally
think you can do whether or not whether
or not transitional justice contributes
to sustained peace or not so what I've
done is to look at the role of trials
truth commissions and amnesties with
respect to the sustainability of piece
five years out and what the purple shows
you are the cases in which if you if you
only look at the blue bars those are the
cases in which piece holds or piece
fails when trials truth mmm STIs are
pursued either during conflict or within
two years of conflict beings being
settled and so what we can see is that
if you if you look at that first bar on
the Left trials were peace holds for a
minimum of five years the total number
of positive cases is twenty eight but it
reduces to eleven when you talk about
cases where trials were only eleven
cases was peace was only sustained in
eleven cases when you look at the timing
so in other words the delaying justice
leads to a much higher correlation with
sustained peace and that's really what
that's intended to show the results
don't look fantastic for amnesties right
amnesties where peace fails is the far
the farthest slide on the right and so I
want to show you one more slide which is
significant about this civil war
scholars Monica talked in particular
have argued in much of her work that the
hardest cases for sustaining peace are
Wars which are ended by negotiated
settlement so twice as likely to result
in the readmission of violence as wars
that are ended through military victory
and if you look here where does the
amnesties are being primarily used
seventy one percent
plus the 3% in the green so 74% of
amnesties are being pursued in cases of
negotiated settlements they're being
used in the most difficult circumstances
so it becomes a very I put these up
again you probably you may or may not
have seen another research on the topic
but it becomes a very difficult debate
that needs to be linked up to when you
start talking about interventions and
ongoing conflict it absolutely has got
to be linked up to the work that we know
from scholars who have really looked at
civil war impact so I think I will
conclude there and come back to some
arguments
thanks jack thanks for coming here while
we listen to the developments in the
Middle East many of us ask ourselves
will Mubarak ever step down and some
have compared the anti-authoritarian
protests to the peaceful revolutions in
East Central Europe that took place over
20 years ago indeed there are some
lessons we can draw from those events
one of them concerns the relationship
between the possibility of peaceful
transitions to democracy and
transitional justice there is a very
vast literature on how the mode of
transition affects the choice of
transitional justice mechanisms but much
less has been said about how the
anticipation of transitional justice
constraints autocrats willingness to
step down from dictatorial power and why
should move right peacefully step down
over the 30 years of his dictatorial
power he's committed numerous human
rights violations against his own
citizens he could face the prospect of
transitional justice in other words he
could find that upon stepping down from
power and giving it up to the opposition
to the members of the opposition whom he
once prosecuted that opposition might
want to cycle settle scores with the
former dictator scholars effected
transitions like the ones that took
place over the third wave of transitions
in Latin America and fourth wave of
transitions in post-communist Europe
have envisioned that maybe some process
of negotiations between Mubarak and the
opposition could occur and historically
these paths have been portrayed as
exchanges of free and open elections for
the opposition's commitment to refrain
from transitional justice or give the
former dictator amnesty but the problem
with this commitment is that it's not
credible it's not credible because the
opposition's delivery of the promise is
temporarily removed from when the deal
is struck in other words once the
autocrats
step down from power and leave office
they leave themselves at the mercy of an
opposition that has incentives to
meg on that earlier promise and punish
the dictator for performing human rights
violations so we can represent this
commitment problem using a simple game
theoretic model that I call the simple
transition in this game we have two
players we have the autograph I don't
have that position the autocrat can step
down or not step down if they step down
they're basically believing that our
position that it will refrain from
punishing the autocrat with transitional
justice daughter brat steps down from
power and then the opposition has a
choice it can keep the promise and honor
the agreement of amnesty or it can bring
it renege on that agreements and punish
the dictator with transitional justice
what's gonna happen in this game depends
on what the two players that we've
modelled here prefer I argue that for
the autocrat
the best situation is if he slips down
from power peacefully and is not
prosecuted with transitional justice if
you can't have that then he'd rather
maintain the status quo the words
outcome for a dictator like like Mubarak
would be if you step down from power and
then was persecuted with transitional
justice what about the opposition well
for the opposition the worst state of
events is the dictator doesn't step down
and the author time rule continues the
second best would be the dictator step
down and who not punished with
transitional justice but the best
outcome for the opposition and that's
represented with the number two is if
the opposition actually win exalt direct
remants and punishes the dictator with
transitional justice after he stepped
down so what happens in this game it's a
very simple way for solving it because
we just start from the end and ask
ourselves what would the opposition do
once given a choice whether to honor
their agreement or to renege on it and
clearly since it's better off reneging
fan of keeping their agreement it would
punish the dictator with transitional
justice well but then the autocrat can
anticipate that if he steps down he's
going to suffer transitional justice so
in this game if it adequately represents
the rationale or the count the
decisional calculus of dictators
dictators should not step down
anticipating that they will be punished
with transitional justice so the
national equilibrium of this game which
we have found together is that autocrat
should never step down and we should
never observe peaceful transitions this
is not what we observe around the world
turning back to the recent history of
Central Europe we can actually focus on
a particular example of transitional
justice illustration the stration is a
good example to focus on because what it
does is it denies public office to
members and collaborators of the former
authoritarian regime and because of that
it's a very particular instrument of
retribution that can be exploited by the
formal position because elected
positions that former collaborators are
banned for from running for easier
accessible to members of the formal
position once transitional justice has
been implemented in other words
illustration eliminates political
competition and that's why it's always
of the formal position so let's see how
countries in East Central Europe most of
whom have transitioned through peaceful
means peaceful negotiations Fred in
terms of meeting out transitional
justice in the form of illustration to
its former autocrats to the to the
communist so this table shows ten
countries in East Central Europe all of
whom accept safer Romania transitions
exclusively peacefully and the shaded
cells show the periods during which
illustration has been enforced and we
see that while in some countries such as
the Czech Republic all of the mania
immediately proceeded to punishing the
former autocrats with transitional
jasper's in the form of illustration
others such as Poland or Hungary
actually of Slovakia waited sometimes
even more than ten years to implement it
unsurprisingly also illustration has
been by far the most popular
transitional justice mechanism the post
communist region so we see that there
there's there is a far from uniform
pattern in adopting transitional justice
well some countries adopted sooner
others adopted later nevertheless it's
almost always adopted so we're still
left with two unresolved puzzles which I
try to explain an address in my book
skeletons in the closet and those
puzzles are to reiterate why given the
choice of honoring and reneging on a
promise of refraining from transitional
justice did the Opposition in Eastern
Europe honor its promises such as in
Poland are Hungary and why would the
autocrats not afraid that they would be
punished with transitional justice
particularly in the form of illustration
and in my book I answered these
questions
within the same framework in which I
framed the puzzle
Social Sciences such as political
science are replete and incredible
commitment problems so I look for
solutions to the simple transitions game
among the the common solutions to
credible commitment games
and one of these solutions has been
proposed by Thomas Schelling in the form
of the kidnappers dilemma so what the
kidnappers dilemma the kidnapper
abducted victim and demands a ransom in
order to release her however the problem
is that if the ransom is paid out the
kidnapper still does not have an
incentive to release the victim because
the victim has seen him or somehow
interacted with him and can then reveal
this information to the police so by
releasing the victim even after
receiving the ransom the kidnapper is
worse off than by actually doing away
with the victim so the kidnappers
promise that he will release the victim
upon receiving the ransom is not
credible there's a credible commitment
problem and the kidnappers dilemma so
how does Thomas Schelling propose to
solve this this dilemma well suppose
that the victim were to give the
kidnapper evidence of some horrible act
that it she has committed in the past
and then upon releasing the victim the
kidnapper would hold on to that evidence
and under the circumstance that the
victim would release her information
about the kidnappers identity to the
police the kidnapper could expose the
evidence against the victim in other
words the victim by keeping some
skeletons in the kidnappers closet
ensures the kidnapper that she will not
rat out his identity to the police so to
solve the credible commitment problem in
the regime transitions game we need to
find some skeletons in the opposition's
closet and intuition as to where we
would find these skeletons can be
provided by the following
two quotes they'll show you the first
comes from a dissident in Poland that I
interviewed while researching my book
and he said when I met questionnaires
the freshness key was the the first post
communist president for
a successor communist in in Poland this
was after the elections the first free
elections he said don't mess with those
files let them be the agents were mostly
your own people the next interview makes
this point more explicit it would be
naive to think that transitional justice
hurts only the communist agents were
everywhere I would expect more of them
among the dissidents because if you were
to infiltrate anyone why was the
Communist infiltrate themselves they
needed snitches and churches and
dissident circles not amongst themselves
that's what the collaborators are so I
argue and demonstrate in my book that
the opposition skeletons consisted of
secret police collaborators among its
own ranks while members of the
authoritarian regime were most eager to
become collaborators of the communist
those who are most useful with the
opposition as themselves
furthermore the oppositionists had very
strong incentives to conceal the fact of
collaborating with the secret police
from their fellow dissidents so as a
result not only was the anti-communist
opposition infiltrated with secret
police agents but it was only also
painfully unaware of the extent of the
Sun formation it simply didn't know how
many of its members had been recruited
by the secret police and well the
easiest way to find out about the
extensive infiltration would have been
to implement a illustration law it was
also the most costly way of finding out
because if the opposition had a lot of
collaborators it would suffer after the
the electrical consequences of having
its skeletons and it's positive sposed
so we can actually model the effect of
this uncertainty of the opposition about
the extent of its infiltration by in by
including one parameter in the payoffs
of our former simple transitional
justice day in this model we would
include an additional parameter I for
infiltration that can take up a value
between zero and one and that determines
whether implementing transitional
justice after the transition hurts the
Communists or the opposition
so while all the other relationships
between the payoffs remain the same the
players still prefer transition without
transitional justice to the status quo
whether or not transitional justice is
desirable depends on the value of this
infiltration parameter so if the
opposition has a lot of corrupt
collaborators among its ranks it will
prefer to honor their commitment but if
it's clean then it will prefer to renege
the problems of the Opposition for its
calculus is that it does not know its
infiltration the Communists however do
and this makes sense because the secret
police was working for the Communists
and not for the opposition so in this
game called the signaling game the
communists act as the sender after
learning how infiltrated the Opposition
is they decide whether to initiate
negotiations or not and the opposition
acts as the receiver of the signal after
observing whether the communists stepped
down or not it decides whether to honor
its agreement or not I'll save you the
trouble of solving this game which is a
little bit more involved but the most
important finding from solving it is
that there exists an equilibrium called
a separating equilibrium where the
autocrats will step down from power only
if the opposition is sufficiently
infiltrated with collaborators or if the
opposition has a sufficient number of
skeletons in its closet the opposition
reads this as a this action of the
autocrats as a signal that it's
infiltrated and it prefers to refrain
from transitional justice it prefers to
actually abide by the promise of
refraining from from amnesty because
it's afraid that if it embarks on an
extensive transitional justice program
it will lead to uncovering collaborators
among its own ranks so in short the
skeletons and opposition supporters have
an enabling effect on peaceful
transitions
we assigned the writings of all four of
our scholars to Tina to like work
through to be the disgusting tonight so
let's see what Tina Rosenberg made out
of that thank you jack and thank you all
for coming tonight
in my defense my book is only
medium-thick
certainly by the standards of the
Harriman Institute we've heard
presentations from for fascinating
scholars on different aspects of a
subject that a couple of decades ago no
one would have dreamed was a real
academic discipline of transitional
justice but it seems to have become one
we've we've heard from routine title
about the new ways that the world is
thinking about transitional justice and
new ways of evaluating it we've heard
from Leslie than Jim Morey on the
effects quantitative approach to the
effects of amnesties truth Commission's
and trials on keeping the peace in
countries that are attempting
transitional justice either during or
after conflicts for a very interesting
presentation on illustration and game
theory which I will get back to and Lara
nettle from Monika Nalepa and Lera
nettle fields presentation on her book
on which looked at the effects of the
International Criminal Tribunal for the
former Yugoslavia on Bosnia and found
that in contrast to the the naysayers it
actually has a moderately positive
effect would you say and all of this is
interesting all of this opens up vast
doors to study new aspects of all of
these things but I'd like to make a
couple of comments first focusing on
Monica no 11
search illustration and my comments are
really I'm not a political scientist I'm
a journalist and so I come to things
really through a different approach much
more anecdotal but in my opinion her
analysis of the different sides in this
game of lustration or not ministration
leaves out a few important things that
I'm sure that she will want to pay
attention to in her next book on the
subject and one of those is that I think
she seems to not pay attention to the
fact that opposition's and ruling
parties are not monoliths they're
divided and certainly among the
Opposition in Poland there was
tremendous ideological division the
there was a group of people who went
through the various names for them the
real poles was one name for them who
were very much always Pro illustration
there was a group of people who are
never Provost raishin for example in
1979 out of Mick Nick who is the sort of
an intellectual leader of this group
wrote a very important essay called
maggots and angels and in that essay it
was a reply to another historians
article condemning the passivity of
Polish intellectuals throughout history
making it went one-by-one through the
quote maggots unquote of pones history
arguing that occasionally conformity was
justified at least to the point where
Outsiders should withhold judgment on
those historical figures Mick Nick's
theme hid the overwhelming theme of his
life his writings as a Polish dissident
was warning his fellow dissidents and
fellow anti-communist activists not to
fall into gsella tree in the 1985 letter
from prison he wrote I pray that we do
not change from prisoners into prison
guards in the New Republic he wrote
about this the two stages of the
struggle for freedom and wrote that the
first the struggle for freedom is
beautiful
the second phase of revolution is not so
beautiful psychology of vengeance and
hatred develops mick nick has spent his
entire career warning against vengeance
and hatred and i think he would put
illustration into that category he had
always been against it the thing that
made what he thought even more intense
was a phenomenon of the Polish
transition that I think also affected
other transitions and I think it's one
reason we have to look at how a country
arrived at a negotiated settlement and
that was the round table Mick Nick and
Quran and the the in Valencia and the
other Polish dissidents participated in
talks with the ruling Communist Party
and the most intense of those took place
at a small group called the round table
and it produce an ideology internet in
itself which many people in Poland
condemned that it was referred to as
round table ISM and it created bonds
between the the most conciliatory and
the two groups that became stronger than
their bonds with their own hardliners in
their own parties and at the end of the
round table talks Mick Nick and Yara's
else key probably had more in common
than Yara's else key had with certain
other hard real hard liners in the
Communist Party believe it or not yar
dosti was not those people or making CAD
with the the real polls in the
opposition and they made agreements
there that that both sides later on felt
that they had to live up to so I think
there I'm just pointing this out to say
there are other factors here beside that
it really cannot be reduced to a chart
where you have yes and no in various
points and the form effect took the form
of revolution took Poland was a
particular movement where the Solidarity
movement went on for years before there
was a transition the people who were
against the regime were at that point
fairly well known that was not the case
in Czechoslovakia where it sort of snuck
up on people all at once and then people
had to do with the sorting out
afterwards all these different things
affect later on how you make decisions
about whether you have illustration or
not and what form that mustard
can take another point I want to bring
up that I think is important to remember
is that many of the people in the
opposition would not feel a common cause
with the collaborators among them they
would feel that those people had lost
their they had forfeited their
membership in the ranks of the
opposition the German opposition to the
Communist Party in East Germany
afterwards many of the people that I met
spent evening after evening after
evening hanging out talking about who
among them was a Stasi collaborator they
did not feel affection for those people
they wanted to take them and put them in
a box and dump them in the sea they they
would have no problem with illustration
that uncovered collaborators within
their ranks because that they felt by
the act of collaboration those people no
longer belong in their ranks I also want
to talk a little bit about an aspect of
thinking about transitional justice that
I don't think has been mentioned tonight
but also is important when we look at
what what is it that we want
transitional justice to do and how do we
get there and to me one of the things
that's extremely important is thinking
about how you change a political culture
that allow the country to fall into
dictatorship and I find that to be a
supremely important question there are
many many different goals that one can
have for transitional justice but to me
this is an overwhelmingly important one
how do you get a country how do you move
a country from being a country where
people don't think for themselves where
they accept blindly the arguments given
to them by the state they don't consider
that citizens have rights that citizens
can act against the state or independent
of the state how do you move that to a
country where people are think of
themselves as people with rights the
state having limited power people having
thoughts of their own and not just
listening to the loudspeaker and I think
it's useful to look at a a
systematically at two different regions
of the world where there has been
transitional justice and those are Latin
America and the totalitarian communist
regimes of Eastern Europe the
differences are important and and one
can categorize them and look at what
they say about what kind of transitional
justice you can have and and you do want
the first difference between them is
that these two groups of countries
although I understand that they were in
an in themselves very different Chile
and Guatemala were extremely different
regimes Poland and Romania were
extremely different regimes but they had
basic similarities that I'm going to
lump together for purposes of comparison
one group Latin Americans with with the
Eastern Europeans first of all there was
a different kind of dictatorship
authoritarian dictatorship usually by
military coup in the Latin American case
communist totalitarian dictatorship to a
greater or lesser extent in Eastern
Europe or former Soviet Union case and
they had different implications the
Latin American dictatorships sought
silence from their people the Eastern
European sought their people's political
participation and that affects the level
of societal complicity military
dictatorships gained and held power with
the complicity of a segment of society
usually the upper class in Latin America
but the abuses that Latin American
dictatorships carried out were usually
carried out by a very small group of
people we know who ran the the neighbor
mechanic school deaths
death camp in Argentina we can name
those people we know who a lot of the
tortures were we know who ran the death
squads victims often run into their
tortures on the street in Uruguay or in
in in Argentina it was the average
person in Latin America was not
necessarily complicit in these crimes in
Eastern Europe things were very very
different here the lines of complicity
for upholding the communist government
were much more complicated they
and like veins and arteries inside the
human body even the most natural
responses of self-preservation in a
communist society where innocence also
acts of complicity with the government
for example a journalist knows that a
critical article about the government
will get her fired so she writes an
uncritical article a father worries
about his son's free chun-hee so he
tells his son
don't complain in public about the
scarcity of oranges people are told to
go to the May Day Parade so they go to
the May Day Parade these are ordinary
citizens doing what ordinary citizens do
in a communist society but such quote
normal collaboration help to keep the
regime alive beyond orb on one of the
Czech dissidents put it very well the
question isn't what some they did in
Eastern Europe we all have to ask
ourselves to what we did so that's one
difference the second difference is the
nature of state crime in Latin America
the generals crushed people with murder
torture and disappearances acts of
violence focused on a small group of
individuals these crimes were in fact
crimes at the time of their commission
they were illegal under existing law and
they were committed by individuals whom
it is possible to bring to trial at
least legally politically there's other
problems in Eastern Europe the situation
was very different for decades Stalinism
was violent on a scale unimaginable in
Latin America but Eastern European
regimes under Stalin were also some of
them very violent but after Stalin's
death with the exception of Albania most
of the regime's in Eastern Europe were
keeping power not through violence but
through corruption and coercion the
secret police bureaucracies and the
political commissioners who took away
people's passports took away their jobs
took away their children's right to
schooling were commissions they were not
necessarily active individuals they were
acts to the state groups to the state
bureaucracies and they were not illegal
they were the very foundation of the
communist system communist repression
required a bureaucratic apparatus to run
and that requires a very different way
of thinking about how you deal with it
once it's gone in in short the Latin
American military dictatorships
of criminals and the Eastern European
communist dictatorships with criminal
regimes a third difference is in a
legacy that these two systems have left
behind in Latin America less so now but
for many years after the military
dictatorships fell the threat of the
return of the generals was was very
present the civilian democratic
governments could not punish the crimes
of the military because the military
still had a loaded gun to their heads
democratic governments were too weak to
punish their militaries they they hit on
truth Commission's as a second best they
were an option available in Argentina
and in Chile because trials were really
not politically possible in Eastern
Europe who had a very different kind of
threat governments they were not to weak
they were too strong they abused their
power over their people
communism itself was shot in the heart
and will not return but the unchecked
power of the government is still a
threat that remains in many Eastern
European and especially former Soviet
countries
it left a poisonous residue people got
accustomed to seeing governments with
near absolute power to see law law
twisted daily to suit political ends to
see no checks on government for someone
who grew up under communism the idea of
citizen rights was a new idea and so
what you have today our governments that
in some ways are still too strong in the
sense that they abuse the rights of
their people that means what you're
looking for in terms of transitional
justice is going to be something quite
different than you want to look for in
Latin America you have different threats
different levels of government power
today and different types of toxicity
left in the society all those things are
things you have to think about when you
when you decide how you are going to
deal with the past so I'll stop there
thank you very much listening to to Tina
just now I think it was striking to see
the the gap between the comments of a
journalist who was reporting on these
matters in Latin America and for a
period in Eastern Europe and the
scholarly work that is being presented
here and I think I also represent a
point of view that doesn't quite mesh
with the the scholarly work that has
been presented this evening there's a
disjunction between my experiences as
someone working to try to to promote
human rights and dealing with efforts to
to use what has become called
transitional justice as a way of trying
to to protect human rights my own
engagement with mechanisms of what we
now call transitional justice started in
1983 and at that point the Argentine
military having lost a a war against the
the British had become discredited and
how to yield power and before yielding
power they purported to to Amnesty
themselves
for the crimes that they had committed
and that became an election issue and
the candidate who rejected the amnesty
was elected and that set in motion the
the current concern with what we now
call transitional justice president
Alfonsin ordered a process to
investigate what happened to people who
disappeared during the the military
regime the name Truth Commission was not
used but that became the popular name
for the Commission because there had
been a group of mothers of the
disappeared and they wanted to know the
truth about what happened to their
children and so it was popularly called
a a truth commission to to meet that
demand and he also set in motion what
became a adjust this process the justice
process was aborted along the way there
were a number of military revolts the
the Argentine government put them down
but in the process alfonsín backed away
from the justice process his successor
pardoned those who had been convicted in
other Latin American countries got the
message that it was too difficult to do
justice to prosecute and punish the the
military officials who had been
responsible for the disappearances and
torture and other crimes in in Argentina
and so truth Commission's acquired a
greater popularity that was one of the
factors that
was important to me some years later at
the time of the the wars in the the
former Yugoslavia in 1992 at Human
Rights Watch we published a report which
I used the term war crimes in the title
it was the first time that I had used
that in any of our reports and we called
for the establishment of what became the
the International Criminal Tribunal for
the former Yugoslavia there were
actually three factors that influenced
that call
the three factors were first this was
July 1992 the the war in Bosnia had
started in April 1992 we wanted to call
attention to the the seriousness of the
crimes that were being committed in
Bosnia and so we wanted to differentiate
them from other things that we had
reported upon previously so we used the
term war crimes in the title of our
report and we also called for the
establishment of a war crimes tribunal
the fact that the justice process had
failed in Latin America because of the
lessons of Argentina was another factor
because we wanted to try to get back to
the idea that trials and criminal
prosecutions were an appropriate way to
deal with such serious violations of
human rights and and the third factor
was what may may seem like
an obscure point are the international
law but it was quite quite significant
the obscure point of international law
was that under the Geneva Conventions
the provisions that deal with what I
call the grave breaches which means war
crimes only appear in the sections that
apply to to international armed
conflicts they don't appear in common
article 3 of the Geneva Conventions they
don't appear in protocol 2 to the Geneva
Conventions and most of the conflicts
that we had focused on up to that moment
were internal armed conflicts and the
general understanding at that time has
changed today but the general
understanding then was that the concept
of war crimes only applied to
international armed conflicts but
because what was going on in the former
Yugoslavia was an international armed
conflict there were three recognized
States there was Serbia Croatia and
Bosnia Herzegovina we thought the
concept of war crimes did apply to that
armed conflict we wanted to to highlight
that the International nature of the the
armed conflict and therefore that was
also part of the the call for an
international war crimes tribunal so
those were the factors that actually
entered into the call coincidence the
report was published and the next day a
journalist named Roy Guttman published
an article in New York Newsday in which
he disclosed the existence of what
became considered something like death
camps Omar Scott
was one of the the two that he reported
upon and the day that his story appeared
in the newspaper the State Department
spokesman at the noon press conference
was asked whether the US State
Department had information to confirm
what appeared in Roy Guttman's stories
story and the State Department spokesman
did confirm the the Guttman report so
suddenly everybody was aware of camps
camps sounded like the the Nazis and so
this call for a war crimes tribunal by
accident caught on and others picked it
up and when we articulated the the
rationale for the for the war crimes
tribunal most of the things that are
mentioned as the sort of instrumental
consequences the impact that we were
trying to achieve were not what we were
talking about during that period we did
not say that it would bring about peace
we did not say that it would bring about
democracy we did not say that it would
bring about reconciliation we did talk
about the the intrinsic significance of
justice and some of the other arguments
that we made in favor of the the
tribunal were directly related that that
is we said we wanted to restore a sense
of justice in places where it had been
disrupted we thought that trials
reflected would reflect respect for the
the victims of abuses we said that we
wanted to help survivors who
to review to resume their lives we said
we wanted to to individualize criminal
guilt we did say that we wanted to to
interrupt cycles of revenge and that
could be seen as something related to to
peace we did talk about deterrence but
we weren't ourselves very much persuaded
by the the concept of deterrence in in
ordinary criminal cases one thinks that
the swiftness ensured us of punishment
are critical to to deterrence there
wasn't any way that we could imagine
Swift and sure punishment of those who
were committing those crimes so we were
we were very hot half hearted in in
talking about deterrence and then the
issue that mattered most to me in
talking about the need for a tribunal
was the the idea of collective political
responsibility for the the crimes that
had taken place and I was very much
influenced by the work of the German
philosopher Karl Jasper's following
World War two and which he had written
about the question of of German guilt
and Gaspar's had differentiated criminal
guilt which could only be individual and
moral guilt which could only be
individual and what he called
metaphysical guilt which could only be
individual but he said all of us
collectively are politically responsible
for this that is not just the people who
actually commit the atrocities but they
commit them in a
political context and others who do not
themselves commit the crimes have a
political responsibility for what took
place and of course in Germany over a
period of time and it didn't happen
until about two decades or so after
World War two
there was an assumption of political
responsibility that is a large number of
Germans even if they were too young to
have committed crimes during World War
two even if they weren't born at that
time did come to feel a kind of
collective political responsibility and
that seemed like something very
important and so those were the the
kinds of things that we were concerned
with in calling for the establishment of
the the Yugoslav tribunal a series of
sort of unanticipated developments
actually led to the tribe tribunal I'll
mention just one I mean the scholarly
literature I think has a tendency to
make these things look as though they
follow some orderly pattern some
predetermined pattern it didn't work
that way one of the the things that
happened was that James Baker became the
political campaign manager for george w
bush's George HW Bush's campaign for the
presidency and so his deputy Lawrence
Eagleburger became Secretary of State
Eagleburger had been ambassador to
Yugoslavia he spoke serbo-croatian he
was known as Lawrence of Yugoslavia and
Eagleburger
was very unhappy that he has
the Secretary of State was going to be
somehow blamed for allowing this to go
forward you remember the George HW Bush
was faced with two crises at that moment
one was the crisis in Somalia the other
was the crisis in in ex-yugoslavia
and : Powell was supposedly supposedly
advised George HW Bush we do deserts we
don't do mountains and so the u.s. went
into Somalia and allowed Yugoslavia to
go forward and so Lord and Lawrence
Eagle Berg a no great champion of
transitional justice became a supporter
held a press conference to announce his
support for the creation of the Yugoslav
tribunal and named ten persons including
Slobodan Milosevic including Radovan
Karadzic including Ratko Mladic who
ought to be brought to trial before the
the u k-- Slav were for such a tribunal
Lawrence Eagleburger put the United
States on record as a supporter of the
creation of the Yugoslavia Buell and
when the the Clinton administration came
into office Bush having been defeated
Madeleine Albright as the US ambassador
to the UN picked up the the effort that
Eagleburger had launched and she led an
effort at the UN Security Council to
actually establish the the the Yugoslav
tribunal I won't stay with the the
Yugoslav tribunal except to say that I
actually consider it an immense success
I mean it has held trials of people from
from four countries that is from Serbia
from Croatia from Bosnia hurts
governor from Kosovo the fact that it
has tried people from all of the
countries that were involved in the
conflicts not just from one of the the
countries is an enormous contribution
they have been fair trials not
everything was perfect about them you
know they've lasted too long they've
been very expensive and and so on
but the fact that they were fair trials
is an enormous achievement
they have apprehended all but two of the
persons who were indicted by the
prosecutor for the the International
Criminal Tribunal for the former
Yugoslavia they have inspired the
creation of courts in Bosnia Croatia and
Serbia that have continued the process
and have prosecuted and brought to
justice
many of the criminals who could not be
tried in The Hague by the International
Criminal Tribunal for the former
Yugoslavia this is a spectacular success
if you want from my standpoint the
significant indication of the success
which relates to the the concept of
collective responsibility think of what
happened in November when Boris haddock
the the president of Serbia went to
Vukovar and apologized for the massacre
that took place at ukuko var and then
Evo your sip of it the the president of
Croatia reciprocated and went to a place
nearby where 18 Serbs were massacred and
apologized for that Massacre the fact
that the presidents of Croatia and
Serbia have come forward and apologized
in on behalf of their countries for
these crimes is an immense achievement
and from my standpoint demonstrating
that collective political responsibility
is really the most significant
accomplishment I can think of for the
the International Criminal Tribunal for
the former Yugoslavia just a word or two
on the question of illustration Tina I
think addressed the things that I want
to say but she did so much better than
than I could I would point out only that
she mentioned Adamek neck that if you
think of the other great dissenters of
the the former Soviet bloc if you think
of Sergey Korolyov
in in Russia and if you think of vaclav
havel in the the Czech Republic these
are not great advocates of illustration
they like Adam ethnic were very dubious
about the illustration process and many
places where illustration took place it
actually didn't take place right away
and it got to be part of the political
struggle in those countries that is
political figures who saw advantages for
themselves in discrediting some of their
opponents were very often the the
proponents of illustration it was not
entirely a debate that was focused on on
issues of justice any rate Mustaine
point of those who were engaged in the
struggles you were trying to have an
impact
on ongoing aspects or ongoing crimes or
sometimes you were dealing with crimes
that were past but you were trying to
have an effect but mostly you were
trying to have an effect by doing
justice not by serving other purpose
purposes justice is an end in itself
it's not merely a means to to something
else and at least from my standpoint and
different people who were active in this
effort had different concerns but at
least from my standpoint the most
important instrumental purpose was
trying to to create that sense of
collective responsibility for crimes
that certain individuals committed but
they only committed with the the
political support of many other persons
in the in those societies thank you
well thanks so much for that
wide-ranging set of comments the
discussants we're pretty gentle so I
don't see any need to go directly to
back to the panel for rebuttals if you
all have things you want to say in
response I'm sure you can work it in as
we do the Q&A so in a minute I'm going
to open it up to anyone in the audience
who wants to ask a question just line up
at that mic and we'll we'll take your
questions while you're thinking of your
good question I have one that I want to
ask on the theme of bargaining and since
Monica and Leslie are our to bargaining
oriented people this might be for you
but it could really be for anybody on on
the panel so used to be that the people
who wanted to bargain with perpetrators
were skeptics of transitional justice
who saw trials as a problem getting in
the way of bargaining with the bad guys
to try to get them to agree to step down
voluntarily in exchange for an amnesty
but what I've noticed lately is that now
it's actually the transitional justice
advocates that are often big proponents
of bargaining in fact one of the claims
that gets made for indictments is that
either an indictment or the threat of
indictment can be used as pressure on
human rights violators to get them over
a barrel somehow in the bargaining
process the question is exactly how
what's the logic through which this
mechanism works and sometimes the idea
is that you threaten to indict them but
then if they step down from power you
don't follow through this raises the
questions of what
do you make that commitment credible
especially in a world in which according
to international law as I understand it
right now you can't give an amnesty for
war crimes crimes against humanity or
genocide so you don't have any of those
mechanisms to make the commitment
credible unless you happen to have one
of those convenient skeletons in the
closet I may be the ICC has skeletons in
its closet but but other mechanisms
though seem even more convoluted like
the idea that after you've indicted
someone like Bashir if he promises to
behave well for the next 12 months
you'll say okay we will hold the ICC off
for 12 months through action of the
Security Council and sort of dole dole
out a stay of justice 12 months at a
time this seems pretty politically
convoluted so I don't know I'm wondering
to anyone in the panel whether they
think that there actually are credible
effective ways to use either indictment
or threat of indictment as a bargaining
tool or whether this is an idea that
just doesn't hold water
well bargaining is very much part of the
the criminal justice process in the
United States that is plea bargaining
takes place all the time the American
criminal justice system such as it is
would break down completely in the the
absence of plea bargaining I don't think
that you can expect that kind of plea
bargaining in the international justice
field when it involves high-level
perpetrators outside the United States
plea bargaining
and a comparably recognized phenomenon
and you would get significant resistance
to it from non-american participants in
the the process and it's hard for me to
imagine it in the case of a Bashir I
can't imagine that Luis moreno-ocampo
would engage in it political figures
might try to to engage in in something
like that but not the the prosecutor
directly
Radovan Karadzic says that Richard
Holbrooke promised him that he would not
be tried if XY and Z took place I don't
know what Holbrook said to to Karadzic I
don't rule out the possibility that that
Holbrook did offer care ejection
opposite an opportunity to to get off
but it wasn't something done in
conjunction with Richard Goldstone at
that time it would have been entirely
separate so it would have been a
political effort but not a prosecutorial
effort
two of the bargaining international
contacts it was back to a conversation
over lunch students at Columbia except
for a very small percentage of potential
and bactine that actually do get invited
by the ICC
but issuing such an indictment against a
certain perpetrator changes the
his or her expectations about how
lengthy needs to be the next one
persecuted so it actually alters a lot
of the decision calculus that whose
individual is going through in a weight
that I would think quite similar to be
bargaining role on
and justice context and also that is
situated pre-market was that we some of
the perpetrators
with low-level yeah um I don't think it
works and and the reason that I don't
think it works is because what we know
from scholars of international security
and from practitioners of international
security is that four instruments of
coercive diplomacy to work that is but
they're using economic sanctions
military force whatever it is and in
this case international justice when
you're talking about ongoing conflict
for these instruments to have an effect
on the decisions that they're targets
the war criminals in this case make they
have to be contingent there has to be
the credible belief on the part of the
person who's being indicted that if they
change their behavior that instrument
the the force of that instrument will
will be altered and the law is not built
to work in that way so I don't I don't
think when you start to use the law as
an instrument for effecting peace and to
quote Ocampo who said to a group of us
to add Oxford in I think it was 2009
law is a tool for restraining violence
so despite where it started I think that
there's been quite a high level of
articulation of of the of the goals
being about restraining violence about
peace and about deterrence although I
fully understand the mix and the very
different and more fundamental beliefs
that started this out although I will
say with all due respect my first
thoughts on this being about deterrence
came when I listened to you speak at a
conference at Bard College in 1998 when
you talk quite a lot about the deterrent
effect that the ICTY had had from Bosnia
to Kosovo you know it did you know that
wasn't one of our goals but what an
impact happened if you looked closely at
the crimes that were committed in Kosovo
they were essentially not the crimes
that were the subjects of the
indictments for what had taken place in
Bosnia and Croatia they were they were
different kinds of crimes there was no
counterpart to the siege of Sarajevo
there were no camps in the the Kosovo
situation they weren't there wasn't
anything like the the Schreber needs a
massacre there were some small-scale
massacres that took place in Kosovo and
my view of those massacres had been that
they weren't necessarily centrally
directed they were instances in which
the KLA had ambushed Serbian troops and
then a local commander thought that the
the KLA who were involved came from a
particular village and committed a
massacre a small-scale massacre at that
village rather than a sort of centrally
directed effort and so I think in fact
you know even though terrible horrendous
things happened in Kosovo maybe ten
thousand people were killed in in Kosovo
the actual crimes committed were not the
crimes that had become the subjects of
indictments in Bosnia and Croatia they
were different and there was in fact a
deterrent impact but that wasn't what we
imagined when we we called for the
creation of the International Criminal
Tribunal for the former Yugoslavia we
didn't think we didn't know that it
could get to that point and I just a
great discussion so my question is sort
of a a reaction and then really a
thought question for all of you or
anyone who wants to answer
and my question is is really sort of you
so Rudy you know you started us off
talking about the normative developments
legal normative developments around
transitional justice and how we and how
courts are thinking about that and I
thought it was a nice actually that are
you've had a nice book end to that which
is bringing us back to law as law and
law as justice and calling for justice
sometimes is is all that it's about and
that's all that I thought you give a
very strong justification for why
sometimes as all it needs to be about
and and isn't that enough and I thought
Leslie that that your slides and and I
saw your discomfort and talking about
the numbers but knowing that you had to
talk about the numbers and the impact
ties in I think to the this larger
debate when we think about that the
politics and we talk about the politics
of transitional justice then what is it
that we were actually trying to measure
which goes back to the goals so so my
question really is how should we be
thinking about justice in transitions
and it strikes me that if we want law to
act as law and restraining violence and
and yet it's we seem to be most
comfortable and maybe its most effective
after the transition and that when law
it becomes a tool of politics during
conflict and trying to whether law
becomes a bargaining chip to negotiate a
transition that's what it felt like the
panelists were very uncomfortable about
law acting as law because in fact it
wasn't it was a proxy for politics so my
question is is really it's part of the
problem that we're using these we're
using a lot of both act as law and we're
using law to act as politics and we need
to be thinking more concretely about the
phases in which were actually want law
to act as law and the phases in which
we're using law to act as politics and
if that's true would just invite your
reflections about what that means for
the research and the questions we should
we should be asking that scholars should
be asking and how it should inform
policymakers
advocates in the moments because we're
always felt was advocated in the moment
of of conflict and I think today's
headlines about Egypt is just is one
example of that so anybody want to
answer how to sequence transition and
justice my work that I was presenting
here is is all pitched at saying wait
because if if the if the goal is as as
our NIR has suggested which is it's
really fundamentally about collective
responsibility about individual
responsibilities about guilt and
innocence then I don't understand why
logically it's necessary to pursue that
goal prior to the resolution of conflict
if it's about something else then we're
in a very different game and what I was
trying to show is that if it's about
something else it's not working very
well right so all all the evidence and
all the argued and arguments suggests to
me that it's it's the wrong domain to be
and so I'm very you know I think that's
in a sense an answer to your question I
hope yeah I guess where I come in on
this is that I just picking up on what
Leslie said it yes there's more
scholarship now but a lot of us were
there at the beginning Aria and I'm
Argentine by birth and was a citizen of
Argentina at the time that I started my
interest on in some of these questions
so and I don't distinguish as crisply
between what happened in Latin America
and Eastern Europe and partly because of
the role of the US and the broader
geopolitical support of certain groups
that were in opposition to what was
called communist
Gurria that were opposing family you
know white Christian values in lat
America and and certain other groups
that were doing the same in South Africa
and I don't see it as a kind of a
messianic moment that brought all of
those transitions to come to light but
rather really serious geopolitical
changes that happen and then the
question becomes what to do in the
periphery right who's the we that
decides that there's going to be a
tribunal in one place and illustration
another so I'm very interested in the
discourse that's used in in the panel
and by by scholars and journalists and
and those in the region now one thing
that was interesting is that I think
everyone on the panel agreed even though
there's wide disagreement on the panel
on the the notion that using the word
crime matters so Tina referred to a
country where there are criminals versus
a criminal regime and and Aria referred
to the importance for human rights watch
of talking about war crimes and
certainly the NGOs one of the big
changes in the discussion of
transitional justice is the
globalization of it the advent of NGOs
and other actors that are busy
mobilizing for different institutions
and using a certain language and that
shift from a political language to the
language of war crimes and the law of
war you know you know it creates a
different space it's a different you
know when it relates to the use of
transitional justice now when there
isn't an end right where the piece
hasn't arrived and it's in the midst of
conflict so what we're seeing is that I
think this really affects the kind of
empirical and normative work because
there are a lot of different values and
goals on the table right I mean there
are people who say well does it work
according to what like what is the
purpose and you know I do think and I
differ with our end is that the stated
goal of the ICTY according to the
Security Council it's chapter 7 powers
was peacemaking because that is the
power that the Security Council had to
create a tribunal otherwise the Security
Council is not in the business of
creating tribunals and it was explicitly
the only power that was related to the
tribunal they said that for peacemaking
purposes a court would and then they
went reckon
that it would achieve this through
reconciliation through gold stone gave a
very big speech in the beginning of his
of his prosecutorial work saying that it
was important to have entities from
every one of the different ethnic
nationalities and which is a form of
affirmative action in criminal law
because the idea was that this would add
would play some role towards the peace
so my concern is that there are a lot of
different values that it you know it
gets back to your concern about the
sacred though that justice seems like a
you know outside of this picture and
that there's a discomfort and I think
anxiety among several folks you know
here and elsewhere about this idea of
bringing in a language of political
bargains that they're competing values
they just you know their concern is that
that's not the language of justice so
that you know there's a lot to say these
are just some thoughts following up on
the the talks and some of the questions
I had told our panelists that we would
be ending around 7:30 but I think we can
take one more question unless people
need to rush so please thank you um I've
been following the events in Tunisia
Egypt another month African and Middle
Eastern countries absolutely yeah my
name is Amy fast I'm not really feeling
it in any place and I heard someone say
that that this could be make a
comparison to to 1989 and the fall of
communism
and I'm wondering our entire spoke about
applying the experience of Argentina to
to Yugoslavia Postiga Slavia and I'm
wondering if how how they experience the
post-communist experience in Eastern
Europe might be applied to the events
happening today
I don't know now look I think that it's
it's very difficult to foretell how
these things were will evolve in in the
the Egypt case I'm very skeptical that
Mubarak is worried about the the
possibility of being put on trial
Mubarak before he was president of Egypt
before he was vice president under Sadat
was the commander of the air force in
Egypt he has retained his strong
military connections whatever regime
comes into being in Egypt the military
is going to be a decisive force in Egypt
when he appointed Suleiman as his vice
president it seemed to me that he was
signaling to the military that his son
was no longer in the picture and that he
was going to a leader of the military as
the the person who he wanted as his
successor and so it's it's extremely
difficult for me to imagine that
whatever might take place in Egypt
that there will be a trial that might
involve Mubarak whether there could be a
truth commission is a different question
I also think it's a different question
as to whether there might be some
prosecutions depending on how things
evolve of the police who took off their
uniforms
to to beat up and in some cases kill the
the demonstrators in Tahrir Square so I
can imagine something like that in Egypt
I can't imagine Mubarak being put on
trial I don't know enough about Tunisia
to really have any sense of how things
will evolve what little I I do know is
that there was you know great popular
hatred for the the wife of Ben Ali and
for members of her family for their very
significant involvement in in corruption
and if I were imagining whether there
would be trials in Tunisia I would guess
that corruption would be the the most
significant focus of any trials that
take place but it's not a country I know
about and you have to you know have a
sense of the circumstances in that
country to be able even to speculate
about how things might evolve well
thanks so much
you